I thought it wasn't you got it this
terrific actress to play your mom it's
really your mom it is so your mom is
present I think we have a picture of you
and your mom here on the show your mom
is present during a lot of peace you
reliving these incredibly embarrassing
moments yeah how's that how would she
like first of all does she is she
getting into it at all being being a
known person I think she is actually
like I think she's thirsty for it like
she's actually she acted a she's not an
actress but she just took to it so
naturally and she was great but she is
like I asked her you know are you
nervous like she's been asked to do an
interview for vulture magazine and she
was like no I don't care and I was like
okay and she I think she cares like
she's getting into it she's like she
just an Instagram post she did I don't
know if you guys have been probably not
but she's just like there's something
I'm huge in Japan and my he's off the
deep end
yeah she's thirsty for the followers
yeah yeah I know it's this good this is
gonna get really bad really soon yeah
early nervous yeah she's gonna be my
she's gonna have like a sponsored room
in Vegas or something you know it's
gonna get crazy it's gonna well I I know
Andy we were talking backstage both of
us absolutely loved the show it is it's
really I think it's so well done it's so
well shot and you to really and inhabit
these people so well so I have to okay
my daughter to watch all of them but up
sewed three okay that's good yeah she's
not allowed to watch episode three until
she's 48 which is one most of us begin
yeah